le projet s'appelle north shore thales
la grande firme française est un
partenaire majeur il veut répertorier
tous les objets volants dans l'espace et
empêcher les collisions et les débris de
ce projet est d'abord est unique
l'ancien premier ministre pierre marc
johnson y travaille depuis sept ans on
parle ici de 40 à 55 élèves qui a
ensuite soit renouvelée de façon encore
c'est un deuxième objectif une
observation de la terre
pourquoi pour faire de l'anticipation
des feux de forêt des récoles on est en
plein dans l'innovation
c'est ce qu'il faut pour stimuler
l'industrie aérospatiale canadienne qui
en a bien besoin
sinon ce sera le déclin l'industrie va
bien il faut décider si nous allons oui
ou non rester dans cette industrie prend
des moyens auxquels le canada soit
toujours un livre lire ère dans
l'industrie de l'aéronautique
le canada se classe parmi les cinq
premiers dans toutes les catégories
assemblage d'avion moteur et simulateurs
de vol civil aérospatiale un rang envié
par des pays concurrents la moitié de
l'industrie aérospatiale et au québec 42
mille emplois trente sept mille à
combler dans les dix prochaines années
la main d'oeuvre ra ce cycle avec faut
investir une innovation français
le fer de lance du rapport faut aussi
que je m'en faut valoriser l'industrie
des lots spéciale au niveau des jeunes
il faut attirer les jeunes dans
l'industrie et beaucoup de négatif
depuis plusieurs années le ministre a
annoncé la signature de six contrats
pour une valeur de 72 millions de
dollars
le rapport charest s'adresse d'abord au
gouvernement fédéral à la veille de
l'élection au niveau de l'innovation du
gouvernement canadien allons-y très fort
dans le développement d'avions capot
neutre et dans les avions autonome les
satellites dont on parle aujourd'hui qui
sont des satellites à basse altitude 2
joue un rôle extrêmement important dans
la surveillance du territoire et dans
notre capacité de gérer en quelque sorte
notre environnement nautique dont le
projet non ce temps les investisseurs
sont l'homme d'affaires charles sirois
les gouvernements du québec de l'ontario
et du canada avec des partenaires
français et italiens jean michel
leprince sera du canada le bourget